[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and these
are the powerbeats
pro
that's right i'm reviewing beats so you
may have seen or heard about these in
various ads like the one you just
watched and i do gotta say even though
everyone in that actual commercial was
technically a professional athlete
i still think the word pro
is overused in products like why are
these the powerbeats pro
but that's a rant for another day at the
end of the day these are just headphones
so when i started using these i just
wanted to know how good of headphones
are they and are they worth the money
because they are
250
so they better be good then again they
are beats now it turns out spoiler they
are pretty great i still think they're
overpriced but as wireless earbuds
they're pretty great so you can think of
these as air pods but if apple actually
cared about them staying in people's
ears so easily my favorite part about
these powerbeats pro is how they're
built like i've never been a huge
earbuds kind of guy but for working out
and for moving around and things like
that you have to have something
lightweight so that's when i prefer
earbuds and they just gotta stay in my
ears and be comfortable air pods never
really fit in my ears i wasn't as lucky
as a lot of you guys but there are two
main differences with these versus air
pods that actually keep them in my ear
so number one similar to jaybirds i've
had in the past
these have a soft touch replaceable ear
tip that you can put different sizes on
so instead of having just hard plastic
one size fits all these are soft touch
and they fit pretty well and then number
two this piece that goes basically over
and around your ear and then holds it
snugly to hold the earbuds in and these
i mean you can either get the kind that
go into the ear up here or over and
around i actually really like these the
first pair of earbuds i ever really used
a lot in high school also had these and
they're
they're not coming off so just generally
i like the design i got the black ones
so they're all matte black plastic
sweatproof of course and the clamp force
while it is snug it isn't too tight uh
and the sign of any good pair of
headphones is that you can wear them for
a long time and after a while you just
kind of forget you're wearing them
that's good okay they also differ from
airpods in a couple of
not so great ways the first one being
this case
it maybe looks like a small case which
is me holding it in my hand but
this is a huge case i mean i guess i do
love that they include a matte black
protective hard shell case with them
with built-in battery and charging
there's a little light on the outside of
the case and there's a pair button on
the inside that's all great but
this actually makes me really appreciate
the air pods and their super small
wireless charging case of course airpods
are smaller but the airpods case is
actually pocketable easily the beats
case
just is not so that's kind of a big deal
sometimes if you're you know walking
around and you just don't have a bag if
you have a gym bag you can toss it in
there but if you don't this is not great
in the pocket and then the case only
charges via lightning so no usb type c
and no wireless charging so even with
all this space and even putting them
actually in the case was this motion
that for some reason i never quite got
used to obviously airpods you just drop
it in there and there's magnets and it's
super easy these have magnets too and
you can see the pins but it's not quite
as smooth you have to get the angle just
right i don't know maybe that's just me
but then the best difference with these
versus air pods is the actual bud so
number one they actually do sound better
yeah you know they're a little bit bass
heavy but i mean come on what'd you
expect they're beats i'm not looking for
a flat sound signature here they're fun
good sounding headphones the seal that
you can create with the rubber tip in
your ear plus the clamp force on the
side and them not coming out
they're a rich good sounding pair of
headphones but then number two the
actual physical buttons on them there's
no touch points there's real buttons so
on the right ear the beats logo is a
button and that can be your play pause
of course double tap for the next song
triple tap for the previous and on top
of each earbud is a volume rocker so
this is better than voice control better
than the swiping across panels of the
sides of headphones it's just simple and
easy regular volume rocker not over
engineered love it of course if you
still want to use voice control you can
they have the h1 chip so you can do a
little hey siri action if you have an
iphone and they'll still respond to that
sorry for triggering anyone's homepod if
anyone still has homepods out there but
anyway that brings us to the couple of
ways that these are similar to airpods
by the way i'm comparing these to
airpods because
well apple bought beats so beats are
apple headphones now but also because
they're just the most popular headphones
everyone has so there's that so the
powerbeats pro have the h1 chip in them
which means they do that sweet instant
pairing with an iphone or just regular
bluetooth pairing with any android phone
just like airpods and there's also auto
play pause when you take them out your
ears and put them back in they'll also
do the siri voice command if you're into
that or if you're on an android phone
you can long press the beats logo to
trigger google assistant or whatever
assistant you use and then the battery
life is just as good so thankfully eight
plus hours of playback easily it has
automatic standby if you put them down
when they're not in the case they can go
for me like a week without charging if i
start with a full battery and a full
case and on top of that there is fast
charging so if they're dead you can drop
them in the case for like five minutes
and it gets you over an hour of listen
time so that's pretty clutch so airpods
2 are already pretty expensive at 160
bucks but like i said these are
250 dollars for a pair of powerbeats pro
so while they are
better than airpods yes especially for
someone like me
i still don't know if i can say they're
worth
250 dollars i guess if you absolutely
must have the completely wireless you
know no wire between the buds then you
know i guess that makes sense these are
some of the best ones especially if
you're an athlete if you need them to be
sweatproof you need them to stay in your
ears while you move around a lot you
need workout headphones i wouldn't blame
you if you got these you'll probably be
very happy with them but just because
these are so expensive i feel like you
can easily recommend something i've used
in the past the jaybird x4s they do have
a wire between them but they're super
lightweight great battery life sweat
proof they stay in my ears just fine and
they're somewhere around like 100 110
bucks so i'll leave links to the
alternative stuff that i'm talking about
right below the like button as well as
links to the beats but i think the price
is the only thing holding these back
overall the stamp of apple is very
evident on the powerbeats pro from the
h1 chip to their very high price tag
but overall there's not much negative
there's not much bad to say about these
so i'll give them credit for that they
actually made a good pair of headphones
um and they live up to the ads so that's
that's good too no regrets
i think i just recommended a pair of
beats on video
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace